hello
can we do any better hello hey
so the
the title of the talks changed a little
bit it was originally revisiting
microwave
revisiting microworld it's now
revisiting window managers
when i originally submitted the talk
proposal
i i hadn't written a line of code but i
had an idea of what i wanted to present
and i got to work a couple of months
later
as always happens with your own ideas
they kind of take on a life of their own
and it morphed into rather than
something like logo
it turned into some something more like
a window manager
so i i have a love-hate relationship
with with the with the desktop
on one hand i love using the mouse i
love the idea of
of of the the affordances you get from
looking at an interface right in front
of you graphically rather than having to
explore it as using the terminal
um but at the same time i'm constantly
frustrated by the capabilities that
modern desktop environments give us um
i find them clunky um i don't like the
way you interact with things i don't
like the way applications
uh exchange data or don't change they
don't exchange data
for that matter so quickly but i want to
go over
some of the the key things i dislike
about desktop environments
and then suggest a few maybe
improvements that that we could
implement in the future so the first
one's
window organization it's setting up your
workspace
and whenever you start like whenever i
start working on a new a project
you you open up your text editor you
maybe open a couple of terminal tabs
you put your browser over to the right
or maybe to the left and then
you code away and then that's all good
you close it down um and you've wasted
all this time
setting it all up uh you've got to move
you're going to nudge the windows about
you've got your hand off the keyboard
you've got to move the mouse and it's
it's all about
it's a little bit frustrating so
why not treat the desktop as a malleable
space just
rather than thinking about putting
windows on the desktop consider the
desktop as being
a space that you can you can bend to
your well so we can literally take a
knife through it
and we split it in half split it again
and split it again
even if you want to go all the way
through you can just split split up the
whole thing
and then the whole thing can be resized
and each window you've created can be
kind of resized independently and then
you can summon
your your tasks into here to get to get
your job done
so that that's one thing
big applications we use big applications
every day
we've got web browsers we've got
photoshop we've got emacs
all these applications that do tons of
stuff and very often you just want to do
one little thing
and you think it'd be great if i could
just take that one little piece of
functionality
from this application and use it use it
by itself
so let's try implementing something like
that
let's make maybe a text editor
so we'll split the the workspace here uh
we've got a text editor component and
we can have a command bar and then we'll
link the two together
so rather than having a single
application
we have small chunks of a functionality
that can tell blocks what to do i can't
kind of visual programming
now i'm unprepared and i haven't got a
file to play about with here
so
so there we go we've we've hooked it up
and now we've taught the the application
how to how to load the contents of a
file
and what if you wanted uh like a buff a
list of your open files
if you're if you're working on a bigger
project again what we do is we just
split the space
and we'll say well let's have some
history in here
and we'll connect make the relevant
connections
and our next time we open a file that
adds itself to the list
and double clicking it again double
clicking it should reopen it
if you hook it up correctly
so there's another another example and
we can we can do we can do something
similar we could we could um
we could replace the text editor with a
browser component
hook the two together
and i don't have wi-fi i hope you can
trust me that that actually works
um so that's and that's another
um frustration i have with desktops the
fact we can't
easily compose um chunks of
functionality as you would do maybe on
the console or in the terminal
it's very easy to create pipelines
whereas traditionally in a graphical
environment
you're stuck with what you've got
next frustration recall
so it kind of ties in with the first
point
of building up your workspace but it it
seems to it strikes me as absolutely
ludicrous in this day and age that
once we've set up our workspace there's
no way of just saying give me that same
thing back
you know you were working on all these
files you set up your workspaces either
way you want that why can't you
the next time you turn on your machine
just have it being exactly the same way
all sets
all state saved so what
what we could do here is introduce the
concept of macros
um so going back to our browser example
we can save that by clicking the save
button
and again we can split the
workspace into four and this time we
just say well give me that we've got a
new macro appeared here
and you can just say give me that
browser back
and we can have four of them that all
work independently
and if we inspect the way they've been
connected together we see each one's got
its own
own set of connections
scriptability so
modern desktop desktop environments they
they they treat the window the windows
are very opaque
you've got your window manager and it
it it just gives a block of video memory
to your to your to your application and
your application just draws draws its
widgets and it's got this complex object
model that represents those widgets
um but then once it's rendered onto the
onto the screen that that representation
is gone
you're just stuck with um
the raw bitmap
whereas if the if the window manager had
a greater notion of what what these
what these components actually represent
uh it would be possible
uh to to to script it through code so
for example we can uh
set up a text editor you're able to have
two text editors talking to each other
and what we can do is we can have the
concept of a mark
so we've got a surrogate cursor that we
can we can click about
and by clicking on a part of the screen
we say this is where i want any future
messages to be sent
so i'll i'll
target the the pain on the right and
then the
pain on the left
so so there you go so by selecting uh
by highlighting some a system command
within the left hand window
and executing it we then caused an
action to appear
on the window that we targeted we could
actually target
itself and enter it and that would
hopefully
replace the active document
so reinvention i mean we've all seen up
applications like netbeans eclipse
um and they all have
they all re-implement the same things
they've got tabs
they've got file views they've got
um they've got weird docking frameworks
for moving little sub-windows about
and despite all the work that's gone
into these things their stillings are
still incredibly inflexible
if i'm using an instance of eclipse and
decidable i want to i want to look at
something in firefox
there's no way for me to inject a
firefox instance in there
so why is this we should be able to
again cutting up our area to what we
want and just using a gesture say
well give me some tabs here
oops
give me a file system list here
text editor and what we're doing is
we're customizing the space to exactly
what we need for the task at hand
rather than accepting the the
functionality that we've been given by
the
the big and flexible applications that
we've got
sharing so
a common frustration you've got you've
got two two you've got you're working
with two app two desktop applications
and they're right beside each other on
the screen
but you can't get data from one to the
other it's like they're it's
they might as well be in different
countries um you know
we're as you as most of us assume are
unix users we've got we've got this
wealth of primitives we normally we're
used to using for passing data between
processes we've got pipes we've got
system five ipc we've got domain sockets
we've got all this but when it comes to
graphical user interfaces all we've got
is save as
we have to save the file and if we're
lucky the other thing will reopen it
and i've just
i've just actually done the talk for the
next slide so just
yeah but well i'll carry on in this
theme
there's no way to to get these two
applications to communicate whereas
what we really want to be doing is
having the two talk to each other
directly
so what could we do about this
so let's start with our our browser that
we saved earlier
um we'll get rid of that because we
don't want that
and we'll go and look at
so
they've got a wee diary the amount of
sleep i've managed to get over the last
week
and now what what we've got we've got
this this data on a web page but we want
to do something with that data
now i've encountered this situation
loads of times in my life as a
freelancer where people want to scrape
data off a website
and normally what you do is you use curl
and you'll copy it to your your local
system
and then you'll run it through some sort
of script that'll extract some data
and then you'll turn into a csv file or
something why should we have to do that
why can't we say well
oops
oops hook it up
and see
create the document
and if we want to get a say the second
column
we could just give it a little query to
run
and we go and and then all the data just
goes from one process into another
now you'll notice there we've got that
data isn't particularly useful because
it's
it's come out as html elements whereas
what we really want are numbers
so let's split this up again
sculpt something called the sculpt
process which is
is kind of our general purpose
transformer
when one when one task doesn't issue
data in the right format
we can put one of these in the middle
and we just tell it how to change what
it gets given which in this case is a
table cell
and there we go we've got another
another set of entries underneath on the
list
that give that extract those numbers as
numbers into into a
table that we can then take on later and
manipulate we could it's easy to see how
we could do aggregate operations on that
or how we could maybe export it to a
variable in a script or something okay
so the final the final frustration is
well that it was actually
ipc was what i just covered and now i'm
going into sharing but
sharing so if i'm let's say i've i've
been working on a really important
document
uh text was up all night writing that
now i've written this document now if
you want if
you want to share if you want to share
this with a friend
there's various ways you could do it if
you're the less technical client well
we'll save it as a file they'll upload
it to their
email and then they'll send it as an
attachment
if you're a bit more technical tavi you
might save it to your hard drive and
then start up a local web server and
share the url
you might upload it to ftp but
this text document it's not just a
window into a file it's a data source in
itself
so why can't we just say
give me an http server
and serve the contents of the file
and then if we go and visit it on
we'll see we get we get the content
coming up so
we we've we've we haven't had to bounce
the disc there we've just
taken our environment and asked the
environment to to work
work to our needs rather than us having
to work around limitations of the tools
that we've been given
so why the 80s why am i what was this
obsession i've got with the 80s anyway
why not
um the 80s
i mean the 80s are mostly known for bad
music and worse fashion
but the it's also for me it was it's
maybe
the closing of one of the golden golden
ages of um maybe
research into experimental programming
languages and environments
you know really the heyday of
environments like small talk
self boxer oberon all all these and all
these environments were
these were all created in the late 70s
early 80s late
towards the late 80s all this amazing
stuff that was built that's
disappeared for 20 years and now it's
starting to make a wee reappearance
and the one i've plundered the most from
is is oberon
oberon's uh it's an operating system but
not an operating system like
we probably know it today uh it's a
thing it runs
all runs in a single process so it's
really just a kernel
it's single threaded it has an event
loop
and it manages a bunch of recursively
laid out rectangles that might sound
familiar
it's it's very like a browser
it was all written by by two guys one
nicholas worth
and uh and somebody else and as a
i don't know his name sorry um and
there's a fantastic book on it there um
if you can read that url it's um
the book actually contains the entire
source code for the operating system so
it's
a 400 page book but more than half of
that is code but it's
what's amazing about it is how simple
the code is i mean obviously they were
they were writing at a time when they
didn't have these complicated machines
but
the the serious beauty and the
simplicity of how it all falls together
so what's the goal of what i'm doing
here
i've tried to create what i've termed
disposable ad-hoc computational spaces
sounds like a mouthful but really what
i'm
what i want to do is i want an
environment i'm not interested in
creating something that can be polished
i i'm not for a minute saying you could
use this to create world-class
applications
that's just not the goal the goal is
that a lot of the time you've got
you have ideas and there's all this
boilerplate in the way and acting upon
your ideas
you know if you want to if you want to
do some 3d you've got to
set up a webgl context then you've got
to find a library that works if you want
to talk to an arduino you've got to
download the software and then install
the right libraries for the peripherals
that are correct
connected to your machine if you want to
if you want to make a website you've got
you've got to download all that you've
got to start with
your you know your template html
document and install
all the your style sheets and your
bootstrap and whatever anyone's using
these days
whereas what you really want to do is
you want to verify if the id is possible
if it's feasible if it's something you
want to work on properly if it's
something that's worth going to the
effort to do all that work that
that that kind of ramp up for and that's
the that's the goal behind this this
system that we're building
i'm not interested in the underlying
elegance the idea here isn't to create
lots of little components that do really
cute things and then have to assemble
hundreds of them to get something useful
we're trying to find that pragmatic
middle ground where we get these
components that
are um that are useful for
specific tasks themselves and if they're
not it doesn't matter if there's a bit
of overlap and functionality here and
there
what's useful what the point is is that
you can actually just just use them
and finally i don't care about
performance i mean this this is all
implemented in javascript
uh it's not for writing world-class
games it's not for mining bitcoins
it's for it's just purely for
experimentation
why do in javascript well we've got the
the hierarchical display model that i
alluded to earlier it's great for i mean
you can see the
i mean this this slideshow itself is
running inside the same
the same system for slicing and this is
the the hierarchical display works
perfectly you can just nest your devs
inside each other
css is great for rapid prototyping with
interfaces
it's it's a joy to work with if you've
ever tried building interfaces with the
likes of java swing
or qt
the sheer little the tiny amount of time
it takes to actually
prototype a new ui concept is is
is great multimedia support you'd be
crazy to try and make an environment
like this without good
multimedia support we expect there to be
videos and audio support and the
browser's got all of that
flexible object model we're not tied
down to classes
uh and rigid inheritance and that's
great for
messing about with different concepts
because if you
you don't have to go to that um that
effort of designing a class hierarchy
you can start off with
you know a function that returns a
couple of closures and then
uh you can move on and then extract it
into something and then build your let
your object model evolve with your
system
and finally it's everywhere the thing
that what worked against all these
systems in the 80s like small
talk and the selfs and all this stuff
was there were no machines about that
could actually run these things
that were in the hands of everyday
people
whereas now we've all got this
incredibly powerful run time on every
pretty much every system in existence
so maybe that's what i alluded to my
my uh the abstract my talk when i said
well maybe this is the time for for
tools like this to
to start coming back so i think i've got
time for a quick demo
i'll try to fit in um
so when i the the the
initial motivation for building the
system was actually teaching
teaching children programming and when
it comes to teaching i
i like to i i like to take a concept
that exists in the real world
and then i try to work out how we could
maybe implement that in code
and then build on that solution so i
i've taken a very simple
uh idea a set of traffic lights
so we'll start off
with our traffic lights and
um some code
now what we're doing here is we're
wiring up uh
we create something called a context
which again i i said is like in a black
box for
uh that contains all the state that the
programming language uses
and so we wire those up
and we'll need a button because the
context can be start and stopped
started and stopped button bar there
and then i'll i'm going to cheat i'm not
writing any code today
uh
so let's let's start that and hope it
works so there we go so
running a bit of code there and it's
just we've just i've just started off
the first two states
flashing between red and red amber i
don't know how traffic light's working
germany i've almost i've been run over
almost remember three times since i got
here so
this is how they work where i come from
so we just got to add a add a few lines
so after that we go green
so we'll add a little bit of code here
green
on and we'll delay there and hopefully
and then we'll add the the state that
goes back to
yellow
now you'll probably notice this this
language i'm using here doesn't really
look like javascript it doesn't really
look like ruby it doesn't really look
like python but it looks a little bit
like all of them
it's it's uh when we were teaching when
we started teaching kids
uh coding we found that they had an
enormous amount of problems with
things like timeouts and you know you
mean to do this in javascript
uh and idiomatic javascript not atomic
generators or anything but you would you
would have to have a couple of state
variables to track the amount of time a
light had been in a specific state and
and the current state and the next state
the lights were going to go into
and for a beginner that is a lot of
stuff to track just to
make a simple sequence occur so we
uh we developed this really simple
language that allowed them allows them
to
uh to write the code in a more
synchronous style
so we've got that working let's let's
take it into the real world
so
so that's the can you see that yep so
that's this that's the wee car we've got
there and we've got a
set of traffic lights there so again
the thing i want like i said i mentioned
earlier about getting rid of the boiler
plate
so we've got this we've got these
flashing lights and we're quite happy
with that but we like to make we'd like
to make an effect in the real world
uh now normally if you want to start
integrating with hardware you've got to
you've got to find the right you've got
to find an environment to use you've got
to find
you've got to find the right libraries
that work with the thing you're you're
wanting to do
and i don't like that i would prefer
there to be services
you know why can't we have a service
that just offers you access to the
the relevant hardware and then we can
interface with that so let's do that
so we'll create um what's called imp
but we'll create and we just tell it
which pins we want to use on the
microcontroller
and i'll set up a few others for later
and we just bind this to the
the same the same scripting context and
by doing that it's just given those
the functions that control those lights
to the same code so now we can say
pin four right false
so excuse me but i'll do this
pin six false and then in here
so it's red on so that'll be pin four
right through and hopefully
yay got a light of
there we go see it and then we can we
can we can go out and fill the rest and
i'll just do one more
so what we've done there is we've taken
us we've taken it we've taken a simple
programming solution
uh uh so a simple program programming
problem
and we've we've solved it in a couple of
ways
and we've done so without uh having to
mess about with libraries having to mess
about with setting up you know canvas
bootstrap code without having to
do all the stuff you normally have to do
to get off the ground
and we can we can immediately start
focusing
on problem solving
and yep i'll leave it there
you